[Applauso]
buonasera
che cos'è la storia la storia e la
ricostruzione del nostro passato ma è
anche una forma di memoria collettiva e
oggi parliamo di memoria e la memoria
l'abbiamo sentito proprio in questa sala
fino adesso è la base su cui costruiamo
la nostra identità sia come individui
che come società ora come in una mappa
geografica non penso non possiamo
trovare i nomi di tutte le località di
quella regione così anche la storia è
una specie di mappa in cui non tutti gli
avvenimenti vengono registrati per il
seguente magari a intervalli regolari di
tempo ma solo quelli che la memoria
collettiva di un gruppo umano grande o
piccolo che sia ha interiorizzato ha
strutturato raggruppato ha selezionato
secondo dei criteri di rilevanza di
importanza che naturalmente variano da
comunità a comunità
allora mi sono chiesta ma quali sono i
documenti storici più antichi del mondo
o quelli che in qualche maniera come
spesso succede nel racconto della storia
ci costringono a modificare la mappa
della storia la nostra visione del
passato
bene le 5000 tavolette cuneiformi
ritrovate nel palazzo reale della città
siriana di ebla
risalenti al 2003 cento circa avanti
cristo sono sicuramente dei documenti
rilevanti significativi sono soprattutto
documenti di tipo amministrativo quindi
registrano ingressi entrate nel palazzo
reale ma sono anche trattati
internazionali i primi i dizionari ma
diciamo senza per farla breve in qualche
maniera hanno consentito la
ricostruzione completa dettagliata della
vita politica sociale economica manca
della vita di tutti i giorni di questa
città che non era nota prima della
campagna di scavi fatta dagli archeologi
della sapienza guidati da paolo mattia
cioè prima della scoperta di questa
città si riteneva che gli unici due poli
importante di civiltà a quell'epoca
fossero alla mesopotamia e l'egitto
invece la siria era considerata una
specie di terra di pastori e allora
diciamo voi vi chiederete ma perché un
fisico uno che fa fisica
astroparticellare ci viene a raccontare
cose sopra note sulle tavolette di ebla
e vedete perché i fisici a mano strafare
e quindi ritengono di essere sempre più
bravi degli altri in qualche caso sono
anche molto arroganti e sicuramente vi
assicuro che sheldon cooper e un'ottima
rappresentazione di certi ambienti dei
fisici
io credo che mai nessuno abbia chiesto
sheldon secondo te qual è il documento
storico più antico mai ritrovato
dall'uomo e io sono sicura che
risponderebbe a il documento storico più
antico dell'uomo non ha certo i 5000
anni delle tavolette di ebla bensì quasi
13,8 miliardi di anni
ora siccome sappiamo che questa è l'età
dell'universo quindi è un documento
storico vecchio come
verso e che cos'è questo documento
storico e questo è la radiazione cosmica
di fondo il cosmic microwave background
scoperto quasi per caso da due astronomi
pensa wilson nel 1965
potete avere fatto questa scoperta è
come avere trovato in un vecchio
cassetto della memoria o fisico
un'immagine un self i come oggi diremmo
dell'universo ma non come adesso ma come
era ad appena 380 mila anni dal big bang
quindi 300.000 anni contro 14 miliardi
di anni e come è stato possibile tutto
questo come è stato possibile scattare
questa fotografia
cosa sappiamo dell'universo sappiamo
oggi che l'universo è uno spazio
omogeneo sotto in espansione
anzi le ultimissime scoperte ci dicono
che questa espansione sta accelerando
sempre di più che è nata da big bang che
è il big bang noi fisici per forse per
nascondere la nostra ignoranza diciamo
che una singolarità una fluttuazione
quantistica di un punto ideale di enel
energia elevatissima
ovviamente non posso ripercorrere tutte
le tappe di questi 14 miliardi di anni
però alcune cose vele voglio dire vedete
nei primi dieci alla meno 43 secondi è
un numero estremamente piccolo neanche
lo spazio e il tempo potevano essere
definiti quello che si chiama l'era di
planck dopodiché c'è un'altra tappa
importantissima che avviene intorno a
dieci alla meno 35 secondi tra dieci
alla meno 35 meno 32 come avere sono
numeri incredibilmente piccoli avviene
che l'universo improvvisamente esplode
l'ente mente in maniera vertiginosa come
noi diciamo esponenziale se volete
questo il vero big bang
e allora l'universo passa dalle
dimensioni di meno di un atomo a quello
di un palloncino di un non so un po
bello che racchiude già tutta l'energia
tutto quello che sarà l'universo dopo 14
miliardi di anni
qui e allora andiamo un attimo avanti in
questa inflazione succedono delle cose
importanti per esempio la materia si
separa dall antimateria e perché
l'universo adesso si è fatto solo di
materia è un altro mistero le forze
cominciano a differenziarsi adesso
andiamo avanti quando finisce questo
periodo che dura pochissimo veramente
meno di un battito di ciglia
l'universo è ancora caldissimo cioè 10
alla 27 gradi kelvin finito questo
periodo della cosiddetta inflazione
l'universo però continua ad espandersi
non in maniera vertiginosa come prima ma
continua espandersi espandendosi si
raffredda e allora arriviamo a questa
tappa fondamentale del cosmit del al
punto del cmb che quando la temperatura
dell'universo finalmente si è abbassata
abbastanza perché gli elettroni create
prima possano aggregarsi stabilmente si
sono rallentati per potersi aggregare
con i nuclei dei primi atomi che si
erano creati nei primi tre minuti
dell'universo e quindi si formano i
primi atomi e avviare una cosa
fondamentale che la radiazione e la
materia che prima erano in continua
interazione l'universo era sì caldissimo
questa zuppa primordiale ma opaco con la
creazione degli atomi la radiazione la
materia si separano la radiazione
elettromagnetica e libera di muoversi in
tutto l'universo di permeare l'universo
allora il sì e bio radiazione cosmica di
fondo
un altro che questa prima luce che ha
brillato nell'universo 380.000 anni
appena dopo il big bang la sua
importanza non sta solo nel fatto che ci
dimostra che la teoria del big bang è
vero ma è un vero e proprio archivio
storico perché hai cosmologi dice
continuerà a dire sempre di più della
nascita e dell'evoluzione dell'universo
adesso la mappa che io vi ho mostrato
prima dopo la scoperta casuale fatta
negli anni sessanta in effetti molti
altri strumenti sempre più sensibili con
maggiore precisione hanno ricostruito
questa mappa che è la mappa in tutto
l'universo a noi accessibile
effettivamente ci dice che questa
radiazione elettromagnetica e uniforme
in qualunque direzione ne guardiamo
dell'universo e uniforme tranne tranne
dei piccolissimi punti vedete che il
colore varia perché ci sono delle
piccole fluttuazioni delle piccole zone
dove questa radiazione e più densa
l'universo era più denso e più caldo
intorno a questi punti si sono create
dopo circa un miliardo di anni
le stelle le galassie e così via
ora dicevo l'importanza di questo vero
archivio storico e proprio che è una
miniera di informazioni sull'universo
bene l'importanza c'è questo documento
storico quindi siamo autorizzati
effettivamente come potrebbe dire
sheldon cooper è il più vecchio
documento storico mai ritrovato da
l'uomo è entrato nella memoria
collettiva dell'umanità e vorrei
sottolineare una differenza
i documenti storici che vengono
ritrovati possono avere rilevanza per
una comunità per un gruppo umano ma
possono averne e molto di meno magari
per un altro gruppo sociale e bene
invece la questo documento storico
questa scoperta della radiazione cosmica
di fondo ha valore universale globale
vale per tutta l'umanità perché perché
il risultato di quelle sensate
esperienze di cui diceva galileo galilei
c'è una verità scientifica è una verità
scientifica non è una verità assoluta ma
è una verità condivisibile condivisibile
da tutta l'umanità io mi scuso per
questa intromissione da fisico nel mondo
degli storici e mi fermo qui grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]